From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。
Hey, is that Richard?
嘿，那是理查德吗？
Yeah, it is. Ira!
是的，是他。艾拉！
Yes. Hi.
没错。嗨。
The day Russia invaded Ukraine, Thursday, at the very end of the day, I reached Richard Ensor, Ukraine correspondent for The Economist. He'd started the day in the capital, Kyiv, and spent much of the day traveling.
在俄罗斯入侵乌克兰的那一天，也就是周四，在这一天的最后时刻，我联系上了《经济学人》的乌克兰记者理查德·恩索。他那天一早就在基辅，大半天都在路上奔波。
I've got you on speaker phone. I've just moved into my safe house.
我开了免提跟你通话。我刚搬进安全屋。
What do you mean by safe house?
你说的安全屋是指什么？
Well, I'm in Lviv, close to the Polish border. And in January I came here, and I rented a flat for three months on the off chance that all hell broke loose and there wasn't a spare-- there wouldn't be a spare flat in Lviv available. Because this is the place that everyone was going to run.
嗯，我在利沃夫，靠近波兰边境。一月份我来到这里，租了一间公寓三个月，以防万一局势彻底失控，到时利沃夫可能连一间空房都找不到。因为这是每个人都会逃往的地方。
Wow.
哇。
And so I've had this sort of set of keys in the back pocket of-- you know, just waiting in case catastrophe strikes. And catastrophe struck. And so now when I'm tired and after one of the longest days in my life when you're coming home at 2:00 AM, I've got a place to lay my head.
所以我口袋里一直揣着这套钥匙，就为了以防灾难降临。结果灾难真的发生了。所以现在当我精疲力竭，经历了我人生中最漫长的一天，凌晨两点到家时，我总算有个地方可以休息。
That's incredible that you ended up having to use it and that you are using it.
真没想到你竟然真的用上了它，而且现在正住在里面。
I called up a rental agency, and they asked me what color I wanted the bricks to be. And I was just thinking, I hope I never have to see these walls. So just give me what you got.
我给中介打电话时，他们问我想要什么颜色的砖墙。我当时心想，我希望永远别见到这些墙。所以随便给我一间就行了。
With him was a woman that he met on the train who needed a place to stay before grabbing another train to Poland. The consequences of talking to the Western press are not clear, so she asked me to call her Natalie here on the radio. She's an English teacher, 25, a Ukrainian who grew up a few hours from Kyiv but moved to the city five years ago.
和他在一起的还有他在火车上遇到的一位女性，她在去波兰赶另一班火车前需要找个地方落脚。接受西方媒体采访的后果尚不明确，所以她让我在这里称她为娜塔莉。她今年25岁，是一名英语老师，也是一名乌克兰人。她在离基辅几小时路程的地方长大，但五年前搬到了这座城市。
And when she told me the long, frightening journey she had made that day, escaping the city while the Russians invaded, it wasn't one of those war stories where you think, oh, I can't imagine what it would be like to go through that. In fact, it was exactly the opposite. For anybody who has ever lived in a decent-sized city, it is shockingly, instantly easy to imagine.
当她告诉我那天她逃离被俄军入侵的城市，经历了一段漫长且可怕的旅程时，这并不是那种让你觉得“哦，我无法想象经历那种事会是什么样”的战争故事。事实上，情况恰恰相反。对于任何在像样规模的城市生活过的人来说，这种景象简直太容易想象了，而且这种感觉瞬间就能引发共鸣。
Every moment of it happens in such familiar kinds of places. She was not woken up by sounds of bombing, but by her stepfather calling on Skype from England where he lives.
每一刻发生的事情都发生在极其熟悉的地方。叫醒她的不是轰炸声，而是住在英国的继父通过Skype打来的电话。
And he woke me up and said that Russians are bombing the airport. So I-- you know, I was pretty sleepy, and I didn't believe it. And then I heard the jets. And I was just freaking out. I was panicking. They were bombing somewhere. It was pretty close to me. And it was pretty terrifying.
他叫醒我说俄罗斯人正在轰炸机场。我当时很困，根本不信。然后我听到了喷气式飞机的声音。我彻底崩溃了。我非常恐慌。他们在轰炸某处，离我很近。那真是太恐怖了。
Terrifying, she says, but a very specific kind of terrifying that you don't usually run into.
她说这种恐惧感非常具体，通常不会遇到。
I felt like a baby. Actually-- I'm sorry. I felt like a baby because I was alone in the darkness of the morning-- empty streets, some strange sounds. Nobody is around, and only my stepfather staring at me from the UK on the screen. You know, I felt like I'm not a woman, I'm a baby.
我感觉自己像个婴儿。真的……对不起。我觉得自己像个婴儿，因为我独自待在清晨的黑暗中——街道空荡荡的，发出奇怪的声响。周围空无一人，只有屏幕里来自英国的继父盯着我看。你知道，我感觉自己不像个成年女性，更像个婴儿。
What do you mean you felt like a baby?
你为什么说你感觉像个婴儿？
First of all, you are not able to protect yourself. You are not able to do anything because you're a baby. You're helpless.
首先，你根本无法保护自己。你什么都做不了，因为你就是个婴儿。你是无助的。
I see. Yeah.
我明白了。是的。
And yeah. You just want somebody to come and to save you.
没错。你只想有人能来救你。
She says she didn't want to feel this way for another minute, so she packed her things and called some friends who have a car, told them, we have to get out of the city really fast. They headed over to pick her up. It's not far, but they got stuck in traffic. So many people were trying to flee.
她说她一分钟都不想再有这种感觉，于是她收拾好行李，给几个有车的朋友打了电话，告诉他们必须尽快撤离城市。他们开车来接她。路程不远，但他们陷入了拥堵。因为有太多人试图逃离。
Finally when they got to her, they decided to head to a suburb called Irpin just outside Kyiv, maybe 20 miles. Should be a 40-minute drive on a normal day. One of the friends' parents have a house.
最后他们汇合后，决定前往基辅郊外一个叫伊尔平的小镇，大约20英里远。正常情况下只需40分钟车程。其中一位朋友的父母在那里有房子。
Because there is a cellar, you know. And again, we got stuck in traffic because people were panicking, as we did. And on the way we saw the Russians' helicopters.
因为那里有个地窖。我们再次陷入了交通堵塞，因为人们像我们一样陷入恐慌。在路上我们看到了俄罗斯的直升机。
The helicopters were shooting, she says. Turns out that Irpin was close to one of the big battles in Kyiv that first day over an airport in Hostomel. Russians sent helicopters to seize it, hoping presumably to use it to bring in troops and supplies to take the city. At one point during the day it was reported that they had captured the airport, then later that Ukrainian soldiers surrounded them and took it back. At this point the Russians seem to have it again. So anyway, that is what Natalie and her friends were driving towards.
她说，直升机正在开火。原来伊尔平靠近第一天基辅发生重大战斗的地方，即霍斯托梅尔的一个机场。俄罗斯人派直升机夺取机场，大概是希望借此运送部队和物资以占领城市。当天一度有报道称他们已经占领了机场，随后乌克兰士兵将其包围并夺回。目前看来俄罗斯人似乎又控制了它。总之，这就是娜塔莉和朋友们正驶向的地方。
Seeing this, it wasn't terrifying anymore because we were in the constant state of shock. We were just staring at it, just staring. And we were just trying to save our lives. That's it.
看到这一幕，我们反而不再感到恐惧了，因为我们一直处于极度震惊的状态。我们只是盯着它看，只是盯着。我们当时只想保命。仅此而已。
They got to the friend's house, the woman with the cellar, took a look around. They were so close to all this fighting, and Natalie decided this isn't right. She was going to turn around. She was going to undo everything she had spent the morning doing, go back to Kyiv where she'd just come from and try to get a train from there to the border, which would mean leaving a place where at least there would be some shelter and heading into who knows what. It was hard to decide.
他们到达了朋友家，就是那位有地窖的女性住的地方，四下查看后，娜塔莉发现这里离战火太近了。她决定折返。她想推翻整个上午的努力，回到刚逃出来的基辅，试着从那里坐火车去边境。这意味着离开一个至少还有些遮蔽的地方，奔向不可预知的未来。这个决定非常艰难。
Because everybody was saying, no, stay. You just have to stay. But I was listening to my inner voice. I was just-- I needed to get to Poland, to get out of the country, or at least to west of Ukraine. We were afraid that maybe the borders will be closed soon.
因为每个人都说，不，待着别动。你必须待着。但我听从了我内心的声音。我必须去波兰，离开这个国家，或者至少去乌克兰西部。我们担心边境可能会很快关闭。
It is my point of view. When you move, you stay alive. It is my point of view. I just-- you know, I'm also pretty anxious, and I just feel better when I'm doing something. When I'm on the move, that means I'm protecting myself.
这是我的观点。当你移动时，你才能活下去。这就是我的想法。我也很焦虑，但当我做点什么时，我会感觉好受些。当我处于移动中，意味着我在保护自己。
One guy decided to go with her, somebody who she'd never met before that day but who seemed like a rational guy. She said you want to stick with rational people in emergency situations. The friends drove them to the train station, a local train that could take them back to Kyiv. And when they arrived in Kyiv they hoped to take the subway, but Kyiv's subways were closed because they include these stations that are deep underground that double as bomb shelters. And that's what they were being used for.
有个男的决定跟她一起走，那是她当天才遇到的人，但他看起来很理性。她说在紧急情况下，你得跟着理智的人。朋友们把他们送到火车站，坐上了一列能带他们回基辅的区间车。当他们到达基辅时，本想坐地铁，但基辅的地铁站关闭了，因为那些深埋地下的车站被用作防空洞。那就是它们当时的功能。
And we had to walk. We had to walk, and we were pretty close to the area where military was. Sorry, I cannot name it exactly because I was just busy running.
我们不得不步行。我们必须走过去，而且离军事区很近。抱歉，我不能具体说出那个地方，因为我当时只顾着逃跑。
Were you literally running?
你们真的是在跑吗？
Let's say jogging.
姑且说是慢跑吧。
They finally get to the train station with trains that could take them west to the border. They had no tickets. It was mobbed. Natalie had money ready in case she needed to bribe somebody to get on a train, but it was such a moment of solidarity. The conductors just let people on without tickets.
他们终于到达了火车站，那里有可以向西前往边境的火车。他们没有票。车站人满为患。娜塔莉准备好了钱，以备需要贿赂上车，但那一刻充满了团结精神。列车员直接让人们在没票的情况下上车。
Richard, The Economist correspondent, was on that train with her, and he told me he had never been in a refugee situation with so many cats. He said he felt like everybody on the train brought their cat. Eight hours later she was halfway across the country, 300 miles away, in Lviv, far from the fighting.
《经济学人》驻外记者理查德当时也和她在一列火车上，他说他从未见过带着这么多猫的难民情况。他说感觉火车上每个人都带了他们的猫。八小时后，她到达了该国的一半位置，距离战斗300英里远的利沃夫。
Anything actually may happen, and everything is changing so fast.
任何事情随时都可能发生，一切都变化得太快了。
Like it was just two days ago, she told me, she did a photo shoot with a friend in the center of Kyiv.
就像两天前，她告诉我，她还在基辅市中心和朋友拍过照片。
It was sunny, blue sky. She bought me some flowers, tulips or something. And we were just enjoying and having coffee. And now I am a, like, almost refugee.
那天阳光明媚，天空湛蓝。她给我买了一些花，郁金香之类的。我们当时享受着咖啡。而现在，我几乎成了难民。
It was hard to believe it happened. Even though she was somebody who had thought Putin would invade and she thought that he would quickly try to take Kyiv-- she'd actually been in the process of getting a visa to get out-- but she said most people didn't believe that, told themselves it wasn't happening.
很难相信这一切发生了。尽管她曾认为普京会入侵，也认为他会迅速尝试占领基辅——她当时确实已经在办理签证准备离开——但她说大多数人并不相信，他们告诉自己这一切不会发生。
You know, it is like a little lie to yourself to feel safer.
你知道，这就像是对自己撒个小谎，好让自己感觉安全些。
I got back on the line with Richard from The Economist. He's actually talked to lots of Ukrainians about this and pointed out that the country's media and its president for weeks have been saying nothing is going to happen. Putin was just posturing. And unless you read the foreign press, you probably wouldn't believe Putin was going to invade. Also he says--
我重新联系上了《经济学人》的理查德。他实际上和许多乌克兰人聊过这件事，并指出该国媒体及其总统几周来一直说不会发生任何事。普京只是在虚张声势。除非你阅读外媒，否则你可能不会相信普京真的会入侵。他还说——
The first thing that any Ukrainian will tell you is that their country has been at war for eight years. And so the idea that this or that Russian battalion coming near their border suddenly means that an invasion is likely-- they'll say the invasion happened in 2014.
任何乌克兰人告诉你的第一件事就是他们的国家已经处于战争状态八年了。因此，对于这个或那个俄罗斯营接近边界就意味着入侵即将发生这种想法——他们会说入侵在2014年就已经发生了。
2014 is when the Russian military took Crimea from Ukraine and pro-Russian separatists in two Ukrainian territories seceded from the country.
2014年是俄罗斯军队从乌克兰手中夺走克里米亚，以及两个乌克兰领土上的亲俄分离主义者脱离国家的时候。
And there have been all manner of different false alarms and ceasefires coming and going-- threats, crazy rhetoric-- since then. And so it's such a roller coaster ride, the idea that-- you know, in their minds, the idea that a bunch of troops turning up on the border changes the game for them, it's just the latest chess move or the latest drama. And a lot of people have worked out a great recipe for happiness, which is just turning off the timeline and not reading any of this.
自那时以来，出现了各种各样的假警报和起起落落的停火——威胁，疯狂的言辞——所以这是一个过山车式的过程，在他们看来，一群军队出现在边境就会改变游戏规则，这只是最新的博弈或者最新的闹剧。许多人已经找到了一种获得幸福的好方法，那就是关闭时间线，不去阅读所有这些信息。
What did you see three months ago that convinced you that this might happen and you got an apartment on the other side of the country?
三个月前，你看到了什么让你确信这可能会发生，并导致你在全国的另一边租了套公寓？
Well, the thing that really worried me was-- it wasn't any troop movements. It was the negotiations. On December the 17th, Russia unveiled a list of demands. And you read these demands, and you start to say, oh my god, they don't care, because they're asking for things that they know they can't get.
嗯，真正让我担心的是——不是任何部队调动。而是谈判。12月17日，俄罗斯公布了一份需求清单。你读到这些要求时，你会开始想，天哪，他们根本不在乎，因为他们提出的东西他们明知是不可能得到的。
And the only kind of person who conducts those kinds of negotiations is someone who doesn't really care whether the negotiations succeed or fail. And when I saw that, that's when I realized they're just going through the motions. They're not serious about these negotiations, but they are serious about the troops on the border.
而进行这种谈判的人，只会是一个根本不在乎谈判是否成功或失败的人。当我看到这一点时，我意识到他们只是在走过场。他们对谈判并不认真，但对边境上的军队是认真的。
It's so crazy, though. You have an entire country with millions of people who basically just have to guess what one man is going to do.
但这太疯狂了。你有一个国家，几百万人基本上只能猜测一个人要做什么。
Yeah. And maybe more than just an entire country. Maybe the whole world.
是的。也许不仅仅是一个国家。也许是整个世界。
Today on our program we have an episode of our show that we put together back in 2017 about that man, Vladimir Putin. At the time it was inspired by news that had people guessing what his intentions were and what he was thinking. We wanted to understand him better. And there's one story we found that's Act One of today's show that I have to admit I've been thinking about for weeks as Putin amassed troops around the Ukrainian border.
今天我们的节目中，有一期我们早在2017年制作的关于那个男人——弗拉基米尔·普京的节目。当时节目的灵感来源于人们纷纷猜测他意图和想法的新闻。我们想更好地了解他。我们发现了一个故事，它是今天节目的第一幕，我必须承认，在普京向乌克兰边境集结军队的几周里，我一直在想这个故事。
It's this story about whether he came to power in 1999 by killing a few hundred innocent Russians. So we have that. If you haven't heard it, you really should. And more, including what do Russians think of him? Stay with us.
这是一个关于他是否在1999年通过杀死数百名无辜俄罗斯人而上台的故事。所以我们有这个内容。如果你还没听过，真的应该听听。还有更多内容，包括俄罗斯人怎么看他？请继续收听。
Act One, Going In with a Bang. So have you heard this story? This is something people speculated about years ago but now seems mostly forgotten. It happened right when Vladimir Putin was coming to power. This was back in 1999. Boris Yeltsin was president, running Russia. Putin was the prime minister-- not well known, not well liked, polling at 2% as a possible presidential candidate.
第一幕，轰然登场。那么，你听过这个故事吗？这是人们几年前推测的事情，但现在似乎大多被遗忘了。这发生在弗拉基米尔·普京上台的时候。那是在1999年。鲍里斯·叶利钦是总统，治理着俄罗斯。普京是总理——当时不太出名，也不太受欢迎，作为总统候选人的民调支持率仅为2%。
And then-- Putin had only been prime minister for a month-- there was a series of bombings of apartment buildings in Moscow and elsewhere. 300 people died. Putin blamed it on Chechen rebels, invaded Chechnya, started the Second Chechen War, which he won. It was a popular war, catapulted him into the presidency. When he took office, he had 53% of the vote.
然后——普京担任总理才一个月——莫斯科和其他地方发生了一系列公寓楼爆炸事件。300人死亡。普京将其归咎于车臣叛军，入侵了车臣，发动了第二次车臣战争，并取得了胜利。这是一场受欢迎的战争，将他送上了总统宝座。他上任时，获得了53%的选票。
And even back then when he took office in 2000, there was a question. Did he bomb those buildings himself to create the pretext for the war and his own rise to power? If he did, of course it calls the legitimacy of his presidency into question in a big way, murdering his own constituents-- exactly the kinds of Russians that he claims to be serving and protecting as president. One of our producers, Robyn Semien, talked to reporters who covered this and reviewed the evidence with them.
即使在2000年他上任时，也有一个问题。他是否为了制造战争的借口和他自己的崛起而亲自炸毁了那些建筑物？如果他这么做了，当然这从很大程度上质疑了他总统职位的合法性，谋杀了他自己的选民——正是他作为总统声称要服务和保护的那类俄罗斯人。我们的制片人之一，罗宾·塞米恩，采访了报道此事的记者并与他们一起回顾了证据。
Before we get to the more mysterious aspects of the bombings, a quick summary of what happened. The bombings came in fast succession-- four bombs in two weeks in random locations in Moscow and two other cities. Early September was the first one. A bomb in a truck went off right outside an apartment building, collapsing it. Over 60 people died.
在我们进入爆炸事件更神秘的方面之前，先总结一下发生了什么。爆炸接连发生——两周内在莫斯科和其他两个城市的随机地点发生了四起炸弹袭击。9月初是第一起。一辆卡车里的炸弹在一栋公寓楼外爆炸，导致大楼倒塌。60多人死亡。
Days later, thousands of miles away, another bomb goes off on the ground floor of a nine-story apartment building. Nine stories flattened, killing over 90 people. Within days there was another one, and then a fourth-- buildings destroyed in the night while people were inside sleeping. David Satter was in and out of the country at the time. He's been reporting on Russia since the '70s.
几天后，几千英里外，另一枚炸弹在九层公寓楼的一楼爆炸。九层楼被夷为平地，造成90多人死亡。几天之内又发生了一起，然后是第四起——建筑物在深夜人们睡着时被摧毁。大卫·萨特当时经常往返于该国。他从70年代就开始报道俄罗斯。
It was an atmosphere of panic. The whole country was terrified. People began to fear that any apartment building could be blown up in the middle of the night and any family could be buried under the rubble. There are 30,000 apartment blocks in Moscow. And patrols, night patrols, were organized in all of them to prevent terrorists from putting bombs in the basements.
那是一种恐慌的氛围。整个国家都感到恐怖。人们开始担心任何公寓楼都可能在半夜被炸毁，任何家庭都可能被埋在瓦砾下。莫斯科有3万个公寓区。他们组织了夜间巡逻队来防止恐怖分子在地下室放置炸弹。
The government immediately blamed the bombings on Chechen guerrillas. Scott Anderson is another reporter who's written about the attacks.
政府立即将爆炸归咎于车臣游击队。斯科特·安德森是另一位写过这些袭击事件的记者。
Chechens tend to be more darkly complected than your typical ethnic Russians. So anyone who was darkly complected on the streets of Moscow was subject to arrest or being beaten up. And so a lot of people from the Caucasus, they would just stay inside. They were afraid to go out on the streets.
车臣人通常比典型的俄罗斯族肤色更深。因此，莫斯科街头上任何肤色较深的人都可能被捕或殴打。所以很多来自高加索地区的人干脆待在家里。他们不敢出门。
But this story that Chechens were behind the bombings was kind of fishy. For starters, it was three years after Chechnya and Russia had finished a war, the First Chechen War. Chechnya basically won. They signed a peace treaty. Again, Scott.
但关于车臣人是爆炸幕后黑手的说法有点可疑。首先，那是在车臣和俄罗斯结束战争——第一次车臣战争——三年后。车臣基本上赢了。他们签署了一项和平条约。再次提到斯科特。
What motive did the Chechens have to start this bombing campaign against Russia when they pretty much had everything they wanted? There was no reason to fight the Russians at this point.
当车臣人基本上得到了他们想要的一切时，他们有什么动机对俄罗斯发起这场爆炸运动？此时没有理由与俄罗斯人战斗。
Right. They'd won the war.
对。他们赢了战争。
That's right. They'd won the war.
没错。他们赢了战争。
So why commit acts of terror that were big enough to start another war? And just logistically, it would have been hard to pull off.
那么为什么要进行足以引发另一场战争的恐怖行为？而且从后勤上讲，也很难做到。
Even in 1999, Russia was a very heavily policed state. And so certainly by after the second or third bombing, there were police checkpoints all over-- certainly all over Moscow, all over major Russian cities. So the idea of these bombers moving around-- and these are kind of crude explosives. They're very heavy, 50-kilo sacks of explosives you need to haul around.
即使在1999年，俄罗斯也是一个管控非常严格的国家。因此，肯定在第二或第三次爆炸后，到处都是警察检查站——当然莫斯科到处都是，所有主要俄罗斯城市到处都是。所以这些炸弹制造者到处走动的想法——而且这些是粗糙的爆炸物。它们非常重，你需要搬运50公斤重的炸药袋。
So you need a car. So you're going through checkpoints. And with the whole hysteria against Chechens, certainly anybody who was, again, darkly complected going through a checkpoint was going to be thoroughly searched.
所以你需要一辆车。所以你要经过检查站。而在整个针对车臣人的歇斯底里气氛中，任何肤色较深的人经过检查站肯定会被彻底搜查。
Even some people in the government questioned the official account. David Satter was in Moscow right after the bombings. And a friend who had good connections told David there were people in the security services who suspected the FSB-- that's the modern version of the KGB basically-- might be behind the bombings.
甚至政府内部的一些人也质疑官方的说法。大卫·萨特在爆炸发生后就在莫斯科。一位有良好关系的朋友告诉大卫，安全部门里有人怀疑FSB——基本上就是KGB的现代版本——可能是爆炸的幕后黑手。
So David asked to meet some of those guys in person, and they agreed. But this was such a dangerous idea. They wanted to make sure they weren't caught. So they had this very private conversation in a very public place, in the center of Moscow.
所以大卫要求亲自见见那些人，他们同意了。但这真的是一个危险的想法。他们想确保自己不会被抓住。所以他们在莫斯科市中心的一个非常公共的地方进行了这次非常私密的谈话。
I don't want to give away too many details.
我不想透露太多细节。
It's OK.
没关系。
But I was in a store of some sort, in a building not far from the Bolshoi Theatre. And people coming and going, but we didn't give any indication what we were talking about. Just a couple of men standing there, talking about something.
但我当时在某种商店里，在离大剧院不远的一栋大楼里。人们来来去去，但我们没有表现出我们在谈论什么。只是几个男人站在那里，谈论某件事。
The agents didn't have proof, but some things just didn't add up.
特工们没有证据，但有些事情就是对不上。
For example, the simple fact that the buildings were blown up with hexogen, which is a very, very powerful explosive that's used to top off artillery shells and is available only in one factory in Russia, which is tightly guarded by the FSB.
例如，建筑物被黑索金炸毁这一简单事实，这是一种非常、非常强大的爆炸物，用于炮弹顶部，只有俄罗斯的一家工厂可以使用，并且由FSB严密守卫。
It's also at military bases. But how would terrorists get hexogen at all, the agent said, let alone drive big quantities of it around Russia unchecked?
它也在军事基地。但特工说，恐怖分子怎么可能获得黑索金，更不用说在俄罗斯境内到处驾驶大量未经检查的黑索金了？
When you heard this stuff, were you thinking these arguments were convincing, or were you also thinking, well--
当你听到这些东西时，你是在想这些论点是有说服力的，还是你也在想，好吧——
I wasn't completely convinced that this was a government provocation. But what convinced me was the bomb that did not go off, the fifth bomb.
我并没有完全相信这是一场政府挑衅。但我相信的是那个没有爆炸的炸弹，第五枚炸弹。
The fifth bomb in yet another city, Ryazan. And this is where the story about the Chechens seems to really fall apart and where the story gets truly strange.
第五枚炸弹在另一个城市梁赞。这就是关于车臣人的故事似乎真正破裂的地方，也是故事变得真正奇怪的地方。
September 22, 1999, 2 and 1/2 weeks after the first apartment bomb. A couple of residents in a building in Ryazan noticed something weird. One guy, a bus driver who lived in the building, saw a car, a white sedan, parked outside the building. Maura Reynolds was a foreign correspondent for The LA Times back then living in Moscow.
1999年9月22日，在第一次公寓炸弹发生两周半后。梁赞一栋大楼的几位居民注意到了一些奇怪的事情。一个住在楼里的公交车司机看到一辆车，一辆白色轿车，停在大楼外。莫拉·雷诺兹当时是《洛杉矶时报》驻莫斯科的外国记者。
She talked to the guy, who told her the license plates on the car didn't look right. They had a local city code on them for Ryazan, the number 62. But, he told Maura, when he looked closer, he saw that the number--
她和那个人谈过，他告诉她车上的牌照看起来不对。它们上面有梁赞的本地城市代码，数字62。但，他告诉莫拉，当他仔细看时，他发现那个数字——
It had been written on. It had been drawn on by hand. It didn't look like it was stamped into the metal license plate.
它是写上去的。是手绘上去的。看起来不像是印在金属牌照上的。
Like with a Sharpie or something?
就像用记号笔之类的？
Yeah, like a magic marker on a piece of paper taped over the license plate.
是的，就像用记号笔写在贴在牌照上的纸上。
Oh.
哦。
And that was immediately something that-- he thought, huh?
那立刻就是让——他想，嗯？
So he calls the police. In the meantime, two men get out of the car.
所以他打电话报警。与此同时，两个男人从车里下来。
And start carrying heavy sacks of something into the building's basement. The people jump back in the car. They take off.
开始把沉重的袋子搬进大楼的地下室。人们跳回车里。他们跑了。
That's Scott Anderson again. The local police show up.
那是斯科特·安德森再次提到。当地警察赶到。
They went down into the basement and came running back up saying, it's a bomb, it's a bomb.
他们下到地下室，跑回来喊道，有炸弹，有炸弹。
Ryazan is essentially sealed off within hours. Thousands and thousands of soldiers and police cordoned off the city, and they begin this massive dragnet for these two men and a woman who was in the car also.
梁赞在几小时内基本上被封锁了。成千上万的士兵和警察封锁了这座城市，他们开始对这两个男人和车里的一个女人进行大规模搜捕。
Local FSB start combing through evidence. A detonator was found in the basement.
当地FSB开始梳理证据。在地下室发现了一个雷管。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Here's a TV news clip from them from a documentary about the bombings called Disbelief. The reporter says, "The sacks were discovered by police."
这是一段电视新闻剪辑，来自一部关于爆炸的纪录片，名为《怀疑》。记者说，“袋子是被警察发现的。”
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
The sacks were taken to a lab that concluded the contents were hexogen, the same explosive used to blow up the other buildings, the stuff that supposedly only the FSB and military had access to.
袋子被带到一个实验室，得出的结论是里面的东西是黑索金，就是用来炸毁其他建筑物的那种炸药，据称只有FSB和军方才能接触到。
One day after the bomb scare, Prime Minister Vladimir Putin, who, remember, has only been in the job for a month, launches the second war against Chechnya over the bombings. He says, quote, "The question is closed once and for all. We will pursue the terrorists everywhere. If they are in an airport, then in an airport. And forgive me-- if we catch them in the crapper, then we'll rub them out in the crapper," unquote.
炸弹恐慌发生一天后，总理弗拉基米尔·普京，记住，他上任才一个月，就因为爆炸事件发动了对车臣的第二次战争。他说，引用：“这个问题已经彻底关闭。我们将到处追捕恐怖分子。如果他们在机场，那么就在机场。请原谅我——如果我们把他们在厕所抓住，那么我们就在厕所里解决他们，”不引用。
Meanwhile back in Ryazan, local police find the mysterious white sedan and the two suspects. They were not Chechen. They were Russian-- Russian FSB agents with FSB IDs.
与此同时，回到梁赞，当地警方发现了神秘的白色轿车和两名嫌疑人。他们不是车臣人。他们是俄罗斯人——拥有FSB身份证件的俄罗斯FSB特工。
The head of the FSB, Nikolai Patrushev, goes on TV and is like, there's a totally reasonable explanation for FSB agents to be caught doing this. The whole thing was a drill. This audio of that announcement is from a documentary about the bombings called Blowing Up Russia.
FSB负责人尼古拉·帕特鲁舍夫上了电视，就像是，让FSB特工被抓住做这种事有一个完全合理的解释。整个事情是一次演习。关于那个公告的音频来自一部关于爆炸的纪录片，名为《炸毁俄罗斯》。
First of all, there wasn't an explosion, and an explosion wasn't prevented. But it wasn't good work. It was an exercise.
首先，没有爆炸，也没有预防爆炸。但这不是工作做不好。这是一个演习。
He goes in front of the cameras. He makes this little statement.
他走到摄像机前。他发表了这简短的声明。
Again, Scott Anderson.
再次，斯科特·安德森。
He doesn't take questions. He walks away. It's just like, oh, yeah, that was just a military exercise.
他不接受提问。他走开了。就像是，哦，是的，那只是一个军事演习。
As for the hexogen, there was no hexogen, he says. There were no explosives. The white powder in the bags, he explains, was sugar.
至于黑索金，他说没有黑索金。没有爆炸物。袋子里的白色粉末，他解释说，是糖。
Maura Reynolds talked to people who lived in the apartment building in Ryazan back then. She says people were angry, and they thought their own government had tried to kill them. Though, of course, since this was Russia--
莫拉·雷诺兹当时和住在梁赞那栋公寓楼里的人谈过。她说人们很生气，他们认为他们自己的政府试图杀死他们。虽然，当然，因为这是俄罗斯——
They wouldn't say it quite that way. What they would say over and over again was in the form of a question. Whose interests were served by this? Who had something to gain? It doesn't make sense, but who had something to gain?
他们不会以那种方式说出来。他们会一遍又一遍地说的是以问题的形式。谁从中获益？谁能得到什么？这没有道理，但谁能得到什么？
Would you ask them, who do you think?
你会问他们，你认为是谁？
Yeah.
是的。
And what would people say?
人们会说什么？
Who else? The government. But let me say that some weren't willing to go to say that out loud.
还能是谁？政府。但让我说，有些人不愿意大声说出来。
They would say, who had something to gain? And then there would be a pause, and they would raise their eyebrows. And I would say, who do you think? And they'd say, who do you think?
他们会说，谁能得到什么？然后会有一个停顿，他们会挑起眉毛。我会说，你认为是谁？他们会说，你认为是谁？
At the time there was still something of a free press. People could speak out and did.
当时还有一些自由媒体。人们可以发表意见，而且确实这么做了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
This is tape from a TV special on an independent channel, the NTV network, which has since been taken over by the state. The special is like a talk show with a host, some FSB higher-ups, and people from the building who are pretty mad. Again, this comes from the documentary Disbelief.
这是NTV频道一个电视特别节目的录音，该频道后来被国家接管。这个特别节目就像一个脱口秀，有一位主持人，一些FSB高层，以及来自那栋楼里非常愤怒的人。再次，这来自纪录片《怀疑》。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
He's saying, "The people of Ryazan and many other towns just do not believe all these stories. I'm sitting here and just cannot believe the story the FSB is telling. I myself am a military officer. I was a senior officer for 28 years. I was in charge of countless exercises. What these generals are claiming about this so-called exercise, I just can't believe my ears."
他说，“梁赞和其他许多城镇的人民根本不相信所有这些故事。我坐在那里，简直无法相信FSB讲述的故事。我自己是一名军官。我担任高级军官28年。我负责过无数次演习。这些将军们声称的所谓演习，我简直无法相信我的耳朵。”
All of this unfolds very quickly. Putin becomes prime minister in August. The bombings are in September. The war starts in September also. Putin is the public face of the war, and it's going well. This is when his popularity soars.
所有这些发展得非常快。普京在8月成为总理。爆炸发生在9月。战争也在9月开始。普京是战争的公众面孔，而且进展顺利。这就是他声望飙升的时候。
And on New Year's Eve at midnight, the president at the time, Boris Yeltsin, makes an announcement.
而在除夕午夜，当时的总统鲍里斯·叶利钦宣布了一个消息。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Boris Yeltsin announces-- complete shocking announcement-- that he's going to retire. He's going to resign the presidency, effective immediately. He names Vladimir Putin acting president.
鲍里斯·叶利钦宣布——完全令人震惊的公告——他要退休。他要辞去总统职务，立即生效。他任命弗拉基米尔·普京为代理总统。
Putin's very first act, his very first presidential decree, is to stop all the corruption investigations into Boris Yeltsin. These investigations have been going on. The elections are supposed to be in June. Instead he moves them up to March, which gives opposition parties very little time to organize. And then he wins the presidency outright in March.
普京的第一个行动，他的第一个总统令，是停止对鲍里斯·叶利钦的所有腐败调查。这些调查一直在进行。选举本应在6月举行。但他将选举提前到3月，这让反对党几乎没有时间组织。然后他在3月赢得了总统职位。
So in this incredibly short period, about eight months, he goes from being a complete unknown to being the president of Russia.
所以在这个令人难以置信的短时间内，大约八个月，他从一个完全的未知数变成了俄罗斯总统。
Maura Reynolds says when Ryazan happened she saw it in local news reports, but it wasn't a huge story. The FSB may or may not have planted explosives. It wasn't clear what it meant. And it was quickly drowned out by the invasion and the war.
莫拉·雷诺兹说，当梁赞发生事情时，她在当地新闻报道中看到了它，但这不是一个大新闻。FSB可能栽种了炸药，也可能没有。这不清楚意味着什么。而且它很快被入侵和战争淹没了。
Only in retrospect did it start to seem significant. And in retrospect there were other pieces of evidence that started to seem important. I'll tell you one more.
只有回过头来看，它才开始显得意义重大。而且回过头来看，还有其他证据片段开始显得很重要。我再告诉你一个。
Right after one of the bombs went off in Moscow-- this was the third bomb-- the speaker of the Russian parliament, a guy named Seleznyov, mentioned the bomb, but got the city wrong. Mind you, he was in Moscow, and the bomb was in Moscow. But he said the bomb went off in Volgodonsk. Here's Scott Anderson.
在莫斯科其中一枚炸弹爆炸后——这是第三枚炸弹——俄罗斯议会议长，一个叫谢列兹尼奥夫的人，提到了炸弹，但弄错了城市。请注意，他在莫斯科，而炸弹在莫斯科。但他却说炸弹在伏尔戈顿斯克爆炸了。这是斯科特·安德森。
So you could say, oh, somehow he said Volgodonsk instead of Moscow, except that three days later an apartment building in Volgodonsk was blown up--
所以你可以说，哦，他怎么会把伏尔戈顿斯克当成莫斯科，除了三天后伏尔戈顿斯克的一栋公寓楼被炸毁了——
Wow.
哇。
--raising the question of how Seleznyov knew about the bombing three days ahead of time.
——这提出了谢列兹尼奥夫是如何提前三天知道爆炸的问题。
The next thing that happens is--
接下来发生的事情是——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
--after the bomb finally did go off in Volgodonsk, another member of parliament, a guy named Zhirinovsky, confronts the speaker about how suspicious this looked. He says, you told us on Monday that a building in Volgodonsk was blown up three days before the explosion.
——在炸弹最终在伏尔戈顿斯克爆炸后，另一位议员，一个叫日里诺夫斯基的人，就这看起来有多可疑质问议长。他说，你周一告诉我们伏尔戈顿斯克的一栋大楼在爆炸前三天就被炸了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Zhirinovsky calls the act monstrous and says he'll try to keep the speaker from being re-elected, but he's hard to hear because they keep cutting his microphone off.
日里诺夫斯基称这种行为是骇人听闻的，并说他会试图阻止议长连任，但他很难被听到，因为他们一直切断他的麦克风。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Someone calls Zhirinovsky a scumbag and then a scoundrel who deserves to be shot. Finally Zhirinovsky turns around, walks away, and gets hit in the back with a folder of papers.
有人称日里诺夫斯基是人渣，然后是一个值得被枪毙的无赖。最后日里诺夫斯基转身走开，背上挨了一个文件袋。
There was an official government investigation into the apartment bombings-- trials, convictions-- all held in private, not open to the public or press. People were convicted. They were not FSB agents. They were not Chechens either. There have been people outside the government who tried to look deeper into the bombings, but overall that hasn't gone well, most notably an independent commission of human rights activists, politicians, and investigators. Again, Scott.
政府对公寓爆炸事件进行了官方调查——审判、定罪——所有这些都是私下进行的，不对公众或媒体公开。有人被定罪。他们不是FSB特工。他们也不是车臣人。政府之外也有人试图深入调查爆炸事件，但总体而言情况不妙，最著名的是一个由人权活动家、政治家和调查人员组成的独立委员会。再次，斯科特。
The head of that commission was killed, was murdered, shot to death in front of his house. Another member of the committee died under mysterious circumstances. Anna Politkovskaya, investigative journalist, one of Russia's leading investigative journalists, was murdered in her apartment building. She had written about the-- casting doubts on the apartment building bombings.
该委员会的负责人被杀了，在自家门前被枪杀。委员会的另一名成员在神秘的情况下死亡。安娜·波利特科夫斯卡娅，调查记者，俄罗斯领先的调查记者之一，在她的公寓楼里被谋杀。她曾写过——对公寓楼爆炸事件表示怀疑。
And of course, Alexander Litvinenko came out publicly accusing the Putin regime of doing the apartment building bombings. He is poisoned with polonium in London in 2006 and dies.
当然，亚历山大·利特维年科公开指责普京政权实施了公寓楼爆炸事件。他在2006年于伦敦被钋毒死。
Radioactive poison, polonium-210, slipped into his tea. A British investigation determined two FSB agents had killed Litvinenko and that Putin had likely signed off on it.
放射性毒药，钋-210，混入了他的茶里。英国的一项调查确定两名FSB特工杀害了利特维年科，而且普京很可能签署了批准令。
In his autobiography which came out in 2000, Putin roundly denied any FSB involvement in the bombings, writing, quote, "What? Blowing up our own apartment buildings? You know, that is really utter nonsense. It's totally insane. No one in the Russian special services would be capable of such a crime against his own people," unquote.
在2000年出版的自传中，普京彻底否认了任何FSB参与爆炸的可能，写道，引用：“什么？炸毁我们自己的公寓楼？你知道，那真是彻头彻尾的胡说八道。这太疯狂了。俄罗斯特种部队中没有人会对自己的民众犯下这样的罪行，”不引用。
David Satter has been researching this since it happened and has written two books about it. He's convinced the story went like this. Before the bombings, even before Putin came to power, Boris Yeltsin and his administration were plagued with corruption investigations. He worried they could eventually point to him and his family, especially if some other party or someone unsympathetic to him became president.
大卫·萨特从爆炸发生起就一直在研究这个，并写了两本书。他确信故事是这样的。在爆炸之前，甚至在普京上台之前，鲍里斯·叶利钦和他的政府就饱受腐败调查之苦。他担心他们最终会指向他和他的家人，特别是如果其他党派或对他不友善的人成为总统。
So he looked to appoint a prime minister who he could trust. He fired two other guys in just three months before landing on Putin. Then he and Putin together had the apartments blown up as the pretext to go to war and, in the patriotic glow, to install Putin and quash the corruption investigations.
所以他寻找一个可以信任的总理人选。他在三个月内解雇了其他两个人，然后才选中了普京。然后他和普京一起炸毁了公寓，作为发动战争的借口，并在爱国主义的热潮中，扶植普京并平息腐败调查。
Scott and Maura aren't so sure. For Maura, when it comes to the bombings, she gets that something was done by design and that it appears to be for political purposes. But as for who was behind the bombings exactly, she can't tell.
斯科特和莫拉不太确定。对莫拉来说，说到爆炸，她明白有些事情是蓄意为之的，而且看起来是为了政治目的。但至于到底是谁在幕后策划，她也说不清。
If you ask me what I think, I have to say, to this day, I do not know. But this is what I would say, is that right now, it doesn't matter.
如果你问我怎么看，我不得不说，直到今天，我仍然不知道。但我想说的是，现在，这已经不重要了。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Because whether the government or people around Putin played a role or whether they didn't, the effect is the same. Either you believe what they said about the bombings, that there were terrorists out to kill ordinary Russians, in which case you are frightened and the world is a very scary place.
因为无论政府或普京周围的人是否扮演了角色，结果都是一样的。要么你相信他们关于爆炸的说法，即有恐怖分子企图杀害普通的俄罗斯人，在这种情况下你会感到恐惧，这个世界非常可怕。
Or you believe that your government or someone connected to the government could be bloody minded enough to kill 300 innocent civilians in their beds, in which case the world is a very scary place and you should be frightened. This is how it works in a police state. You should be frightened. And that's how the government exercises control.
要么你相信你的政府或与政府有关的人可能心狠手辣到在睡梦中杀死300名无辜平民，在这种情况下这个世界非常可怕，你应该感到恐惧。这就是警察国家运作的方式。你应该感到恐惧。而这就是政府行使控制权的方式。
It's been nearly two decades since the bombings. And I wanted to know, what do people in Russia think about them? Putin is still their president. How big a deal are they? Are people walking around wondering if their president came to power by killing hundreds of Russian citizens?
离爆炸事件已经过去近二十年了。我想知道，俄罗斯人对此怎么看？普京仍然是他们的总统。这是一件大事吗？人们走在街上是否在怀疑他们的总统是否是通过杀害数百名俄罗斯公民而上台的？
So I interviewed four people who live in Moscow. None of them said they were big supporters of Putin. Three of the four had heard the rumor that he was behind the bombings. None of them believed it or wanted to believe it. "I can't know the truth, so I can't say," a 42-year-old screenwriter told me. A 22-year-old student I talked to said she didn't want to know if it was true.
所以我采访了四个住在莫斯科的人。他们中没有人说自己是普京的坚定支持者。四个人中有三个听过他幕后策划爆炸的传言。没有人相信或愿意相信这一点。“我无法得知真相，所以我不能说，”一位42岁的编剧告诉我。我谈到的一个22岁学生说她不想知道这是否是真的。
As for Ryazan, only one of the four, a telecommunications specialist, had heard anything about Ryazan-- the sacks of sugar, any of that. He knew all the details though, read a book about it. And he believes Ryazan was an FSB drill. The one person who'd never heard the story that Putin might be behind the bombings was Yuliya, a 40-year-old lawyer.
至于梁赞，四个人中只有一个，一名电信专家，听说过梁赞的事——那些糖袋，任何这些。但他知道所有细节，读过一本关于它的书。他相信梁赞是一次FSB演习。唯一一个从未听说过普京可能是幕后黑手的故事的人是尤利娅，一名40岁的律师。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
It's just not something that people discuss. The media doesn't say anything about it, the families don't talk to each other about this, and friends don't talk about this to each other.
这根本不是人们讨论的事情。媒体不提它，家庭内部不谈论这个，朋友之间也不谈论这个。
Does it just seem like old news?
这看起来像是旧闻了吗？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Yes, absolutely.
是的，完全是。
So I ran through all the facts with her, all the evidence that Putin might be behind the bombings. She said she didn't care. Does it sound like a ridiculous theory, I asked. Yes, she said, most likely some ridiculous theory.
所以我把所有事实都过了一遍，所有普京可能是幕后黑手的证据。她说她不在乎。这听起来是一个荒谬的理论吗，我问。是的，她说，很可能是一个荒谬的理论。
Robyn Semien.
罗宾·塞米恩。
Act Two, Mr. Popular. So one of the notable things about Vladimir Putin is that for years he's had stunningly high approval ratings among Russians. In January and early February of this year as tensions rose with Ukraine, his approval numbers rose with them to 71% from the 60s. And back in 2017 when we first broadcast today's program, the press was reporting that his approval ratings were something like 84%, which for a US president, that would be just unthinkable.
第二幕，受欢迎先生。关于弗拉基米尔·普京，引人注目的一点是，多年来他的支持率在俄罗斯人中一直出奇地高。今年1月和2月初，随着与乌克兰的紧张局势加剧，他的支持率从60多上升到71%。回到2017年我们首次播出今天的节目时，媒体报道他的支持率在84%左右，这对美国总统来说是不可想象的。
And we wondered, is that real at all, that 84%, or is that from some institution controlled by Putin? So back then we asked Charles Maynes to look into this for us. He is now NPR's Moscow correspondent.
我们当时感到好奇，那84%是真的吗，还是来自某个被普京控制的机构？所以当时我们请查尔斯·梅恩斯帮我们调查一下。他现在是NPR驻莫斯科记者。
Well, it is real. I mean, these are real polls where large numbers of real people really do answer questions. Russia has two big polling firms that are essentially state sponsored and one that's independent. And all three of these get basically the same numbers. This month, Putin dropped by 2% to 82%. And American pollsters like Gallup and Pew, they also get the same results.
嗯，它是真的。我的意思是，这些是真实的民调，大量真实的人确实回答了问题。俄罗斯有两个主要的民调公司基本上是国家资助的，还有一个是独立的。这三家公司得到的数字基本相同。本月，普京的支持率下降了2%，降至82%。美国的民调机构如盖洛普和皮尤，也得到了相同的结果。
In the 80s?
在80%多？
Yeah, in the 80s.
是的，在80%多。
But are people just saying that they like Putin because they are scared to say anything else?
但人们说喜欢普京是不是因为不敢说别的？
Well, that's part of it, especially with older people. There was a poll done by this Levada Center-- this is the independent pollster in Russia-- saying that 26% of all respondents said they're afraid to share their views of the government with pollsters. So that probably inflates the number, but just how much isn't really clear.
嗯，这有一部分原因，特别是对于老年人。列瓦达中心——俄罗斯的一家独立民调机构——做过一项民调，说26%的受访者表示他们害怕与民调员分享对政府的看法。所以这可能会夸大数字，但夸大多少还不清楚。
So OK, if 82% isn't the right number, do we have any sense of what a more accurate measure of his popularity might be?
所以好吧，如果82%不是准确数字，我们有办法衡量他更准确的支持率吗？
Well, some pollsters say it's the so-called electoral rating. This is when you ask Russians who they'd actually vote for. Like the Levada Center has this poll they do where they say, if the presidential elections were held next Sunday, who would you vote for? And then only 55% say they'd vote for Putin.
嗯，一些民调机构说那是所谓的选举评级。这是当你问俄罗斯人他们实际上会投给谁时。比如列瓦达中心有一项民调显示，如果下周日举行总统选举，你会投票给谁？然后只有55%的人说他们会投票给普京。
And that's, again, the independent pollsters. The state one has a figure that's a little higher, 64%. But that's hardly the 82%, 84% that we've seen.
这是独立民调机构的结果。国家机构的数字稍微高一点，64%。但那绝对不是我们看到的82%或84%。
So what I get from this is take the 82%, 84% approval rating with a grain of salt, but it is true that most people approve of him?
所以我的理解是，对82%或84%的支持率持保留态度，但大多数人确实认可他是事实？
Yeah. He's still really popular.
是的。他仍然非常受欢迎。
OK, so to hear what that approval is all about and what people think of him, we asked you to talk to some people who like him, which you did, people across the country. And then you put together this story about one of them.
好吧，为了听听这种认可到底是怎么回事，以及人们怎么看他，我们请你去采访一些喜欢他的人，你确实做了，采访了全国各地的人。然后你整理了这个关于其中一人的故事。
This is someone I knew wouldn't exaggerate their feelings about the president because they were talking to a foreign reporter, someone I've known for decades.
这是一个我知道不会夸大对总统感受的人，因为他们是在和外国记者交谈，这是一个我认识了几十年的人。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
That's her talking here, Olga Sergeevna Dmitrieva. I lived with Olga Sergeevna and her two children back in the mid-90s when I was an exchange student in Moscow. It was a good five years before Putin arrived on the scene. Over the years she took in several American exchange students.
那是她在谈话，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜·德米特里耶娃。90年代中期我在莫斯科做交换生时，我和奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜以及她的两个孩子住在一起。那是在普京出现前五年。多年来，她接待了几位美国交换生。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
That's her telling me I was her favorite. And I tell her I always say I have a Russian mom.
那是她说我是她最喜欢的。我告诉她我总是说我有个俄罗斯妈妈。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
She says, I always say I have an American son who I don't see as much as I like. We took the tram to her apartment building through the neighborhood I lived in with her family back in the '90s, and she started pointing out all these changes-- a new playground, new stores.
她说，我总是说我有个美国儿子，但我见不到他像我希望的那样频繁。我们乘电车穿过我90年代和她家人住过的社区去她的公寓楼，她开始指出所有这些变化——一个新的操场，新的商店。
And just by the new museum they're building a community pool. Now, none of this was here back when I lived with them. It's all part of the prosperity that's come to Moscow since Putin came to power. And it's why Olga Sergeevna and lots of people in her generation-- she's in her 60s-- it's why they love Putin.
就在新博物馆旁边，他们正在建一个社区游泳池。现在，我住在这里时，这些全都没有。这一切都是普京上台后给莫斯科带来的繁荣的一部分。这就是为什么奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜和她那一代许多人——她60多岁——这就是为什么他们热爱普京。
When I lived with Olga Sergeevna and her family Boris Yeltsin was president, and things in Russia were really, really tough. In fact, there's a poll for that. It says 68% of Russians think nothing good happened in Russia during the Yeltsin years, nothing.
我和奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜住在一起时，鲍里斯·叶利钦是总统，俄罗斯的生活非常、非常艰难。事实上，有一项针对此的民调。它说68%的俄罗斯人认为在叶利钦时代俄罗斯没有发生过任何好事，什么都没有。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Olga Sergeevna says life was hard back then. People didn't have enough money. Grocery stores were empty. And they only began to clear with the arrival of Vladimir Putin.
奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜说那时生活很艰难。人们没有足够的钱。杂货店是空的。直到弗拉基米尔·普京到来，情况才开始好转。
It seems almost hard to remember now, but when Putin first arrived as prime minister in 1999 Russians had no idea who he was. He was this awkward public speaker back then. His suits were ill fitting. The guy never smiled.
现在回想起来几乎很难，但当普京在1999年首次作为总理出现时，俄罗斯人不知道他是谁。那时候他是个笨拙的公众演讲者。他的西装不合身。这家伙从不笑。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Hardly, says Olga Sergeevna, the specimen she sees now.
很难说，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜说，那是她现在看到的样本。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
She told me Putin's appearance was predicted earlier, when mystics said one day a man named Volodya would save Russia. Volodya is short for Vladimir. Lots of the older generation will tell you stuff like this.
她告诉我，普京的外表是早先被预测出来的，当时神秘主义者说有一天一个名叫沃洛佳的人会拯救俄罗斯。沃洛佳是弗拉基米尔的昵称。老一辈中的许多人会告诉你这样的事情。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Nobody thought that savior would be Putin. I mean, let's face it, she says. He's kind of short. No one believed he'd change Russia, that Russia would rise from its knees. But it did rise from its knees. His predecessor, Boris Yeltsin, was seen as this buffoon-- visibly drunk in meetings with world leaders, an embarrassment.
没人想到那个救世主会是普京。我的意思是，面对现实吧，她说。他有点矮。没人相信他会改变俄罗斯，让俄罗斯从膝盖上站起来。但他确实从膝盖上站了起来。他的前任，鲍里斯·叶利钦，被视为一个小丑——在与世界领导人的会议上明显喝醉了，是个尴尬。
Putin was younger. He didn't drink. The fact that he was a former KGB agent at least meant he was disciplined and educated. He spoke German, practiced judo. And he brought an end to the chaos of the Yeltsin years during which the ruble had collapsed several times, the government was constantly reshuffled, and a few insiders, the so-called oligarchs, became billionaires while most everyone else lost their savings.
普京更年轻。他不喝酒。他曾是KGB特工这一事实至少意味着他有纪律且受过教育。他会说德语，练习柔道。他结束了叶利钦时代的混乱，在那期间卢布贬值了几次，政府不断重组，少数内部人士——所谓的寡头——成了亿万富翁，而大多数其他人失去了积蓄。
But as soon as Putin took over, the economy boomed, mostly because of oil prices shooting up. And soon he exiled or arrested oligarchs who'd been running the country behind the scenes. A lot of people talk about how Putin saved Russia.
但普京一接手，经济就繁荣起来，主要是因为石油价格飞涨。不久他就流放或逮捕了在幕后运作国家的寡头。很多人谈论普京如何拯救了俄罗斯。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
If you compare 1994 and 2017, Olga Sergeevna says, the difference is night and day. In 1994 and '95, we didn't celebrate holidays. Nobody was in a festive mood. The theaters were all closed because nobody went. Nobody had money.
如果你比较1994年和2017年，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜说，区别是白天和黑夜。在1994年和1995年，我们不过节。没人有节日气氛。剧院都关门了，因为没人去。没人有钱。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Under Putin, she says, she lives a comfortable life-- has a job, can afford to travel, can go out to eat or to the theater. It's hard to overstate how important this is. During Putin's first decade in power Russians had never lived better, particularly in the bigger cities. People like Olga Sergeevna became part of something that was happening for the first time ever in Russia, the emergence of a middle class.
在普京治下，她说，她过着舒适的生活——有一份工作，买得起去旅行，可以出去吃饭或去剧院。很难夸大这有多重要。在普京掌权的第一个十年里，俄罗斯人从未过得更好，特别是在大城市。像奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜这样的人成了俄罗斯历史上第一次发生的事情的一部分，即中产阶级的出现。
Over time, this economic miracle turned Putin into sort of a folk hero. There's the side of him we know in America, the guy flying jets or riding horses shirtless. But in Russia he's cultivated this image that he's frugal, lives modestly, works all the time.
随着时间的推移，这种经济奇迹把普京变成了一种民间英雄。有我们在美国所知道的他的一面，那个开喷气式飞机或赤膊骑马的家伙。但在俄罗斯，他建立了一种他很节俭、生活简朴、总是工作的形象。
A political analyst told me Putin's seen as the only one who can fix anything or improve people's lives, the one who keeps corrupt bureaucrats in check. He's the good czar. For Olga Sergeevna it wasn't just that Putin made the country better. It was that he could do no wrong.
一位政治分析家告诉我，普京被视为唯一能修复任何东西或改善人们生活的人，是那个让腐败官僚受到控制的人。他是好沙皇。对奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜来说，不仅是普京让国家变得更好。而是他不会犯错。
I love Putin.
我爱普京。
Why?
为什么？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Because he's smart, intelligent, cultured, athletic, she says. He's even a musician, plays and sings.
因为他聪明、有智慧、有教养、有运动天赋，她说。他甚至是个音乐家，会弹奏和歌唱。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
I asked her if there's anything he can't do. Her response--
我问她有什么他不会做的吗。她的回答——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
He can't cook, but he doesn't need to. Finally I said, come on. Isn't there anything you don't like about him, anything at all?
他不会做饭，但他不需要做。最后我说，算了吧。难道没什么你不喜欢他的地方，任何地方吗？
Nyet. Nyet. Nyet. Nyet. No!
不。不。不。不。不！
While we were talking, Olga Sergeevna brought me over to her computer, started scrolling through her Facebook page. She subscribes to a Putin feed just to see what he's up to. And her feed is filled with pictures of him-- Putin snarling, Putin laughing. Doesn't he look like a benevolent lord, she says.
当我们谈话时，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜把我带到她的电脑前，开始浏览她的Facebook页面。她订阅了一个普京的推送，只是为了看看他在做什么。她的推送里充满了他的照片——普京咆哮着，普京笑着。难道他看起来不像一位仁慈的领主吗，她说。
I just want to point out here that Olga Sergeevna doesn't work for the government or Putin's United Russia party. She's an accountant. She has been for decades, with a daughter who lives in London and a son who works for an American tech company.
我只想在此指出，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜并不为政府或普京的统一俄罗斯党工作。她是一名会计。她已经做了几十年，有一个住在伦敦的女儿和一个在美国科技公司工作的儿子。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
One of the things Olga Sergeevna likes best is that Putin stands up to the West. And this is a big thing for Russians.
奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜最喜欢的一点是，普京敢于对抗西方。这对俄罗斯人来说是一件大事。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
As Putin likes to say, when they curse me in the West, it means I'm doing the right thing.
正如普京喜欢说的，当他们在西方咒骂我时，意味着我做的是正确的事。
When it comes to the bad things Americans hear about Putin-- that he's corrupt, that he's secretly one of the world's richest men, or that he's meddled in the American elections-- Olga Sergeevna says that's all lies perpetuated by Western journalists, people like me, a reminder that we have this ongoing joke where she tells me to leave our Putin alone. And she says she means it.
当谈到美国人听到的关于普京的坏事时——他腐败，他是世界上最富有的人之一，或者他干涉了美国选举——奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜说那全是西方记者、像我这样的人散布的谎言，这提醒了我们，我们有一个正在进行的笑话，她让我放过他们的普京。她说她是认真的。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
I ask her about the many opponents of Putin's who've ended up dead-- the journalist Anna Politkovskaya or Alexander Litvinenko, the KGB whistleblower who was poisoned with a radioactive isotope. Who poisoned him, she asked. Some say it was Putin, I tell her. Oh, please. Everyone says it's Putin.
我问她关于普京的许多结局悲惨的反对者——记者安娜·波利特科夫斯卡娅或亚历山大·利特维年科，那个被放射性同位素毒死的KGB吹哨人。谁毒死了他，她问。有人说是普京，我告诉她。噢，拜托。每个人都说是普京。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
The moment somebody sneezes or farts in Russia, Putin is to blame. I say, but what about the opposition leader Boris Nemtsov? He was killed. But she interrupts me and says--
在俄罗斯，任何人打个喷嚏或放个屁，普京都会被归咎。我说，但反对派领袖鲍里斯·涅姆佐夫呢？他被杀了。但她打断我说——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
Nothing of the sort, nothing of the sort. There was an investigation. Nemtsov died over a love triangle. She doesn't buy any of it. In fact, a lot of Olga Sergeevna's opinions are things you might hear on state TV. But I think with Olga Sergeevna and the other people I talked to, people who love Putin, the moments I understand them best are when they talk about the past, everything they went through before Putin arrived.
根本没那回事，根本没那回事。有调查。涅姆佐夫死于三角恋。她根本不信那些。事实上，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜的许多观点是你可能在国家电视台听到的东西。但我认为通过奥尔加·谢尔盖耶芙娜和其他我谈过的人，那些爱普京的人，我最理解他们的时刻是当他们谈论过去时，谈论普京到来之前他们经历的一切。
It's why sometimes I think the real reason people like Putin is not because they believe he'll keep moving Russia forward into the future. It's because they fear someone else, anyone else, might drive Russia back to the past.
这就是为什么有时我认为人们喜欢普京的真正原因不是因为他们相信他会带领俄罗斯走向未来。而是因为他们害怕别人，任何人，可能会把俄罗斯带回过去。
Charles Maynes in Moscow. This past week, he phoned Olga the day that Moscow invaded Ukraine to find out what she thought. She thinks Putin made the right call, that he was going in to help the separatists in Eastern Ukraine who've declared themselves independent of Ukraine and pro-Moscow. She believes Ukrainian authorities were going to attack people in that territory with arms they got from the United States.
查尔斯·梅恩斯在莫斯科。上周，莫斯科入侵乌克兰的那天，他打电话给奥尔加询问她的想法。她认为普京做出了正确的决定，他进入是为了帮助东乌克兰的分离主义者，他们已经宣布脱离乌克兰，支持莫斯科。她相信乌克兰当局打算用他们从美国获得的武器袭击该领土上的人民。
The President of Ukraine, Zelensky, she told Charles he's a clown. Biden's a dope. Putin, still the smartest of the pack.
乌克兰总统泽连斯基，她告诉查尔斯，他是个小丑。拜登是个笨蛋。普京，仍然是这群人里最聪明的。
Coming up, another reason Russians see Putin the way they do. We get to know the disinformation mastermind who reshaped the world of Russian politics into what it is now. That is in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，俄罗斯人以这种方式看待普京的另一个原因。我们将结识那位将俄罗斯政治世界重塑为现状的虚假信息策划大师。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续，来自芝加哥公共广播。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Other Mr. President, stories of Vladimir Putin and those around him. We've arrived at Act Three of our program-- Act Three, Maybe Pay a Little Attention to the Man behind the Curtain.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《另一位总统先生》，讲述弗拉基米尔·普京和他周围人的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕——第三幕，也许稍微关注一下幕后的人。
There's a quote that we heard while we were working on today's program back in 2017 from a writer named Peter Pomerantsev. He said that if the old Soviet Union was 75% violence, 25% propaganda, in today's Russia those numbers are reversed. It's 25% violence and 75% propaganda. And propaganda was radically reinvented under Vladimir Putin, its tactics and its methods, by this one political operative. Sean Cole explains.
在2017年制作今天的节目时，我们听到一位名叫彼得·波美兰采夫的作家说过一句话。他说，如果旧苏联是75%的暴力，25%的宣传，那么在今天的俄罗斯，这些数字是颠倒的。它是25%的暴力和75%的宣传。而且宣传是在弗拉基米尔·普京的领导下被激进地重新发明的，它的战术和方法，是由这一位政治操盘手完成的。肖恩·科尔解释说。
The operative's name is Vladislav Surkov. He was Putin's deputy chief for more than a decade, starting in 1999. In Russia he's what's referred to as a political technologist, but those are a dime a dozen. At the top of his powers, Surkov had a much more ominous, if unofficial title. He was known as a gray cardinal.
这位操盘手的名字叫弗拉季斯拉夫·苏尔科夫。他做了十多年的普京副幕僚长，从1999年开始。在俄罗斯，他被称为政治技术专家，但那些人多如牛毛。在他权力的巅峰时期，苏尔科夫有一个更凶险，如果是非官方的头衔的话。他被称为灰色红衣主教。
He doesn't look like a shadowy mastermind. He sort of resembles Rowan Atkinson, the actor who played Mr. Bean, except handsomer. And he actually doesn't manage propaganda at the Kremlin anymore. But the methods he invented to manipulate people and information, I've even heard them called artistic.
他看起来不像一个阴暗的策划大师。他有点像罗温·阿特金森，那位扮演憨豆先生的演员，除了更帅。而且他现在实际上不再在克里姆林宫管理宣传了。但他发明的操纵人和信息的方法，我甚至听说它们被称为艺术。
See, in the Soviet era the country was run by the Communist Party and the propagandists pumped out literally the party line and tried to suppress all other opposing messages. And then the Iron Curtain fell, a whole bunch of new political parties were created, and it was the messy early stages of a real democracy with parties bickering and vying for power.
看，在苏联时代，国家由共产党统治，宣传人员简直是泵出党的路线并试图压制所有其他对立信息。然后铁幕倒塌，产生了一大堆新政党，这是真正民主混乱的早期阶段，各党派争吵和争夺权力。
And then when Putin became president-- I'm obviously skipping over a lot here-- his right-hand man, Surkov, helped solidify the Kremlin's power by putting together this party called United Russia, which gained majority in parliament and backed Putin. And then instead of tamping down the opposition like the old days, Surkov built a new system where there was opposition, but he dictated what the opposition stood for.
然后当普京成为总统时——我显然省略了很多——他的得力助手苏尔科夫通过组建这个名为统一俄罗斯的党，在议会获得多数席位并支持普京，帮助巩固了克里姆林宫的权力。然后，不是像过去那样压制反对派，苏尔科夫建立了一个新系统，里面有反对派，但他决定了反对派代表什么。
You do not allow political parties to create their own agendas. You just write these agendas for them.
你不允许政党制定自己的议程。你只是为他们写下这些议程。
This is Vasily Gatov. He's been a very high-level player in Russian media for nearly 20 years. These days, he's a visiting fellow at the Annenberg Center on Communication, Leadership, and Policy.
这是瓦西里·加托夫。他近20年来一直是俄罗斯媒体中非常高层的人物。这些天，他是安纳伯格传播、领导和政策中心的一名客座研究员。
Well, we decide one of our parties is left party with some sort of communism. Another party is you're a socialist. And the third party is deep conservative, kind of evangelicals. And the fourth party would be sort of liberal radicals. And that's what Surkov actually constructed.
嗯，我们决定我们的一个党派是带有某种共产主义色彩的左翼党派。另一个党派是你是社会主义者。第三个党派是深层保守派，类似福音派。第四个党派将是某种自由激进派。而这正是苏尔科夫实际上构建的。
And he created whole new political parties and wrote their agendas.
而且他创造了全新的政党并写下了他们的议程。
For example, he created a party called Spravedlivaya Rossiya, Just Russia.
例如，他创建了一个名为Spravedlivaya Rossiya，公正俄罗斯的政党。
Just Russia.
公正俄罗斯。
Yeah. It was a political cadaver.
是的。它是一具政治尸体。
Are you saying cadaver like a corpse?
你是说尸体就像一具死尸吗？
Cadaver, like a cadaver.
尸体，就像一具尸体。
Like Frankenstein.
就像弗兰肯斯坦。
Frankenstein, yeah.
弗兰肯斯坦，是的。
Got it.
明白了。
Created from some sort of pieces of socialist, labor, activist, more pro-government type of labor unions. He also decided that he cannot allow any grassroot activities which would not be vetted by Kremlin. So he decided that he will create also youth movements and write agenda for them.
由社会主义、劳动、活动家、更亲政府类型的工会的某些部分创造。他还决定，他不允许任何未经克里姆林宫审查的草根活动。所以他决定他也将创造青年运动并为他们写议程。
And he also tried to do the same thing with NGOs, like political NGOs or those that control elections' transparency or expose corruption, sort of writing agendas for every one of them in the Kremlin.
他也试图对非政府组织做同样的事情，比如政治非政府组织或那些控制选举透明度或揭露腐败的组织，基本上是在克里姆林宫为他们每一个写议程。
It's like directing a movie in a way.
这在某种程度上就像执导一部电影。
Absolutely. I would even provide you with a very funny hypothesis. In 2001, I think, Russia has been invaded by reality shows, things like Survivor, Big Brother. And he was amazed how scripting can improve even those likely spontaneous interactions between people. And I know that he was very good friends with all the producers of these reality shows. And actually, I think he was once even present at the filming of the Russian version of Survivor.
绝对是的。我甚至可以给你一个非常有趣的假设。2001年，我认为，俄罗斯受到了现实秀的入侵，像《幸存者》、《老大哥》之类的节目。而他很惊讶剧本化如何能改善人与人之间那些可能自发的互动。我知道他是这些现实秀所有制片人的好朋友。事实上，我想他有一次甚至出现在了俄版《幸存者》的拍摄现场。
No way.
不会吧。
Yeah.
是的。
And he's like, if they can do that on TV, sort of fake reality in TV, maybe we can fake reality in reality.
而他就像，如果他们能在电视上那样做，电视里的虚假现实，也许我们能在现实中制造虚假现实。
In a way, yeah.
某种程度上，是的。
By 2003, so about four years into Surkov's tenure as gray cardinal, Vasily says Surkov had built up a whole cadre of deputies that would carry out his agenda with these different parties and other groups. I asked Vasily for an example of how all this worked, and he told me what everybody told me when I asked for specifics. He said, it's not like I was in the room with him. I don't know exactly what he said to whom, nor when.
到2003年，也就是苏尔科夫担任灰色红衣主教四年左右时，瓦西里说苏尔科夫建立了一整套副手架构，他们会用这些不同的政党和其他组织执行他的议程。我请瓦西里举一个例子说明这一切是如何运作的，他告诉我每个人在我询问细节时都告诉我的话。他说，并不是我就和他待在房间里。我不知道他确切地对谁说了什么，也不知道什么时候。
He did tell me about this one case that he heard about from someone who worked with Surkov. In 2004, Vladimir Putin decided that governors shouldn't be elected anymore. They should be appointed by him. It's a long story. But at first, every other political party besides Putin's was against the idea, genuinely against it. But then Surkov manipulated them over to his side. It helped that he controlled their funding and the number of seats they got in the Duma.
他确实告诉了我一个他从和苏尔科夫共事的人那里听到的案例。2004年，弗拉基米尔·普京决定不再选举州长。他们应该由他任命。这是一个长故事。但起初，除了普京的政党之外，每一个其他政党都反对这个想法，确实反对它。但随后苏尔科夫操纵他们倒向了他那一边。他控制了他们的资金和他们在杜马的席位数量，这很有帮助。
And then the parties went through this whole drawn-out public drama, which had all the trappings of democracy. The bill was submitted. There were arguments for and against it, protests around the country. People announce they've changed their minds. There were several votes. And finally, after three months, it passes. All of this, Vasily says, was scripted by Surkov's people.
然后这些政党经历了这一整套拖延的公开闹剧，它具备了民主的所有外表。法案被提交。有赞成和反对的争论，全国范围的抗议。人们宣布他们改变了想法。进行了几次投票。最终，三个月后，它通过了。所有这一切，瓦西里说，都是苏尔科夫的人写的剧本。
The name you hear for all these techniques is managed democracy. Surkov uses the phrase sovereign democracy. I suggested to one person I talked to that managed democracy sounds like a contradiction in terms. He said, exactly. It just means there's no democracy.
你听到的这些技术名字是管理式民主。苏尔科夫使用主权民主这个词。我向我交谈过的一个人建议，管理式民主听起来像是一个词语矛盾。他说，完全正确。它只是意味着没有民主。
I don't want to overstate Surkov's power, nor his malevolence. Apparently he was much more carrot than stick in his approach, explaining why, no, you really want to align yourself with the Kremlin. Here's what's to be gained. And he didn't try to do this with everybody.
我不想夸大苏尔科夫的权力，也不想夸大他的恶毒。显然他在他的方法中萝卜多于大棒，解释为什么，不，你真的想与克里姆林宫保持一致。这里有什么可以得到的。他并没有试图对每个人都这样做。
He maintained, under this managed or sovereign democracy, a certain level of dissent.
他维持了，在这种管理式或主权民主下，一定水平的异议。
Some actual opposition.
一些真正的反对派。
Actual opposition, both in society and press, and even enjoyed this dissent because it was developing natural leaders like Navalny.
真正的反对派，在社会和媒体中，甚至享受这种异议，因为它在培养像纳瓦尔尼这样的自然领袖。
That's Alexei Navalny. You may have heard of him. He's a high-profile activist. He's considered to be the only real opponent to Putin, except he can't run against Putin because Putin's people had him arrested, and you can't run for president in Russia if you have a criminal record.
那是阿列克谢·纳瓦尔尼。你可能听说过他。他是一名高调的活动家。他被认为是普京唯一真正的对手，但他不能竞选普京，因为普京的人把他逮捕了，如果你有犯罪记录，你在俄罗斯不能竞选总统。
To be honest, Navalny emerged within these sandboxes of allowed freedom that Surkov created. And it was important for him because it was making his camouflage of autocracy much better looking.
老实说，纳瓦尔尼出现在苏尔科夫创造的这些允许的自由沙盒中。这对他来说很重要，因为它使他那独裁统治的伪装看起来好多了。
The more you hear about Surkov the man, the more it makes you understand how his whole Truman Show theatrical directing of society developed. He has all of these opposing factions inside of him too, all working in an unlikely but perfect concert together. Back in the early '90s he was a PR guy, designing ads for the richest oligarch in Russia.
你听到越多关于苏尔科夫这个人的事，你就越理解他那整个楚门秀般的社会戏剧执导是如何发展的。他内心也有所有这些对立的派别，都在一起以一种不可思议但完美的形式运作。回到90年代初，他是一个公关人员，为俄罗斯最富有的寡头设计广告。
At that point Surkov said he wanted to be like, quote, "the hero in Pretty Woman." He meant the Richard Gere character. But he's also a huge fan of the anti-bureaucracy, gay, Buddhist beat poet Allen Ginsberg. This is Surkov reciting Ginsberg's poem "Sunflower Sutra" from memory.
在那一点上，苏尔科夫说他想成为，引用，“《风月俏佳人》中的英雄”。他是指理查·基尔的角色。但他也是反官僚、同性恋、佛教徒节拍诗人艾伦·金斯伯格的忠实粉丝。这是苏尔科夫凭记忆背诵金斯伯格的诗《向日葵经》。
And you there standing before me in the sunset and all your glory in your form-- a perfect beauty of a sunflower.
而你站在夕阳下的我面前，以你的形式展现你所有的荣耀——一朵向日葵的完美美感。
You might be able to tell that Surkov studied theater, but he got kicked out of the Moscow Institute of Culture after a fistfight, reportedly. He's written lyrics for a Russian band called Agata Kristi. And so you marry PR and art and performance, plus his time at Russia's main state TV network Channel One-- managed democracy was just the natural culmination.
你可能看得出苏尔科夫学过戏剧，但他据说在一次斗殴后被莫斯科文化学院开除了。他为一个叫阿加莎·克里斯蒂的俄罗斯乐队写过歌词。所以你把公关和艺术以及表演结合起来，加上他在俄罗斯主要国家电视网第一频道的时间——管理式民主只是自然的高潮。
He was kind of entertaining himself.
他有点在娱乐自己。
Again, Vasily Gatov.
再次，瓦西里·加托夫。
It was really funny for him to make these things happen, to achieve certain results, and sort of creative building of reality. Again, as I said, it's a very much Big Brother type of scripting.
让他这些事情发生，取得某种结果，以及某种创造性的现实构建，对他来说真的很有趣。再次，正如我所说，这是非常像《老大哥》式的剧本编写。
He means the reality show Big Brother.
他是指现实秀《老大哥》。
I mean, you need to create a conflict, and this conflict will create the conflict. And then we just roll it out, and people will vote, and that would be fun.
我的意思是，你需要制造冲突，而这个冲突将创造冲突。然后我们只是展开它，人们会投票，那会很有趣。
Besides which, he could totally get away with it. Because not only was he good at it, but in Surkov's time as gray cardinal not very many people were paying attention.
除此之外，他完全可以逃脱惩罚。因为他不仅擅长此道，而且在苏尔科夫担任灰色红衣主教的时期，没有太多人关注。
At this moment people were absolutely uninterested in politics because Russia had a natural economic growth of about 9% a year. And the ruble was kind of taking strength. Credit was extremely cheap. The country was booming. It's easy to build autocracy when country's booming because nobody cares about politics.
在那一刻，人们对政治完全不感兴趣，因为俄罗斯有大约9%的年度自然经济增长。而且卢布也某种程度上增强了力量。信贷极其便宜。这个国家正在繁荣。当国家繁荣时，建立独裁统治很容易，因为没人关心政治。
Right.
对。
And I think Surkov was enjoying this moment because he was not only kind of a shadow cardinal, but he actually was openly cardinaling the situation.
而且我认为苏尔科夫在享受这一刻，因为他不仅是一个影子红衣主教，而且实际上是在公开地管理这一局势。
That is, after a certain point he wouldn't take very many pains to hide what he was doing, which I can imagine the feeling. Here he is carrying off all of these feats of manipulation in secret. You'd think he'd want a little credit.
也就是说，在某一点之后，他不会花太大力气去隐藏他在做什么，我可以想象这种感觉。他在这里秘密地完成了所有这些操纵壮举。你会认为他想要一点赞赏。
On this point, there was a moment when Surkov seemed to be showing his cards a little bit, deliberately. It's a story that Peter Pomerantsev likes to tell. He's the journalist that I recorded earlier. Peter used to work in reality TV in Russia, and he's written a lot about Surkov.
在这一点上，有一个时刻苏尔科夫似乎有点故意展示他的底牌。这是彼得·波美兰采夫喜欢讲的故事。他是记者，我早些时候录过音。彼得过去在俄罗斯做现实秀，他写了很多关于苏尔科夫的东西。
This liberal blogger, liberal photo blogger-- he has a very, very popular blog-- took some photos of the office.
这个自由博客作者，自由照片博客作者——他有一个非常、非常受欢迎的博客——拍了一些办公室的照片。
Of Surkov's office?
苏尔科夫的办公室？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，是的，是的。
He was there to photograph an official meeting, but he said on his blog that he was much more interested in what was in the office.
他当时在那里拍摄一个正式会议，但他在博客上说他更感兴趣的是办公室里有什么。
And that's where you have the phones on his desk with the names of all the opposition political parties.
而这就是你桌上有电话的地方，上面有所有反对派政党的名字。
Like literally there's a whole mess of phones. And on one of them in particular, next to the numbers, there's a bank of buttons labeled Mironov, Zhirinovsky, Zyuganov, all heads of parties.
就像字面上有一大堆电话。其中一个特别的，在号码旁边，有一排按钮标注着米罗诺夫、日里诺夫斯基、久加诺夫，所有党派领袖。
And you have the portrait of-- the photo of Tupac Shakur next to like Machiavelli or something.
还有图帕克·夏库尔的照片，就在像马基雅维利之类的旁边。
Yes, Tupac Shakur the rapper. It's actually next to a picture of Barack Obama.
是的，说唱歌手图帕克·夏库尔。它实际上在巴拉克·奥巴马的照片旁边。
And at the time everyone was like, oh my god, wow, we've got to see inside Surkov's office. And then many years later when everybody realized that Surkov had been funding this liberal blogger, everyone was like, oh my god, he leaked that. He wanted us to feel his power.
当时每个人都像是，哦我的天，哇，我们必须看看苏尔科夫的办公室内部。然后很多年后，当每个人都意识到苏尔科夫一直在资助这个自由博客作者时，每个人都像是，哦我的天，他泄露了那个。他想要我们感受到他的力量。
And he wanted to create an atmosphere where you can never really tell what's true anymore, so everything is suspect. That was absolutely intentional. Surkov himself has come just shy of saying it openly.
他想要创造一种氛围，让你再也分不清什么是真的，所以一切都值得怀疑。那是绝对故意的。苏尔科夫本人已经差一点公开说出来了。
He talks about it in his book.
他在他的书里谈到了它。
This is another shape Surkov is reported to have shifted into. He wrote a novel under the pseudonym Natan Dubovitsky. He won't admit it's really him, but Surkov's wife is named Natalya Dubovitskaya. So everyone's like, nutty coincidence.
这是苏尔科夫被报道转变的另一种形式。他用化名纳坦·杜博维茨基写了一部小说。他不会承认那真的是他，但苏尔科夫的妻子叫纳塔利娅·杜博维茨卡娅。所以每个人都觉得，真是巧合。
The book's called Almost Zero, or Close to Zero. It's about a PR guy who grew up in the sticks, like Surkov did, moved to Moscow to hang out with bohemian artists, like Surkov did, and is now embroiled in the seedy, murderous underworld of illegal book publishing and distribution. Oh, and it's got an English subtitle-- Gangsta Fiction.
书名叫《几乎为零》，或接近零。这是关于一个公关人员在乡下长大，就像苏尔科夫一样，搬到莫斯科与波西米亚艺术家混在一起，就像苏尔科夫一样，现在卷入了非法图书出版和发行的肮脏、凶残的黑社会。哦，而且它有一个英文副标题——黑帮小说。
In any case, Peter says there are these really telling passages in which the hero realizes, oh, wait, everything's made up-- language, politics, every ideology. Everything's fake. I can see through it all. It's an epic kind of cynicism.
无论如何，彼得说里面有这些真正说明问题的段落，主人公意识到，哦，等等，一切都是编造的——语言、政治，每一个意识形态。一切都是假的。我可以看穿这一切。这是一种史诗般的犬儒主义。
It's not cynicism as in like, oh, I don't believe in anything, but almost like, oh my god, I've burst through the shallow shells of morality and ideology and belief.
它不是像说，哦，我不相信任何东西那样的犬儒，而几乎像是，哦我的天，我冲破了道德、意识形态和信仰的浅层壳。
It's like "I'm seeing behind the matrix" kind of thing.
就像“我在看矩阵后面”那样的东西。
Yeah, very much. The Matrix was a super popular film in Russia.
是的，非常像。矩阵在俄罗斯是一部超级流行的电影。
I bet.
我敢说。
Which makes sense if you think about Russian history. I mean, this generation like Surkov or like Putin, they've lived through Communism. They've lived through the mafia state. They've lived through fake democracy, through sort of religious national socialism or an empire building, which they have now.
如果你想想俄罗斯历史，这就说得通了。我的意思是，像苏尔科夫或普京这一代，他们经历过共产主义。他们经历过黑手党国家。他们经历过虚假民主，通过某种宗教民族社会主义或他们现在拥有的帝国建设。
And it's all the same people. And they've gone through so many different modes of being in the last-- what-- 30 years in such blistering progression that they're kind of left with the feeling that everything is a masquerade. So when Surkov says everything is controlled in a construct, what he's actually saying is not a confession. It's a piece of psychological propaganda to say, so there's no point struggling for anything.
而且他们全是同一个人。他们在过去——什么——30年里经历了如此多不同模式的存在，以至于他们有点留下了“一切都是伪装”的感觉。所以当苏尔科夫说一切都在一个构造中被控制时，他实际上说的不是忏悔。这是一篇心理宣传，说是为了说，所以挣扎没有任何意义。
Don't even try to do any of your silly protest movements. So in a way you're killing-- if you tell people that everything is a conspiracy, it doesn't lead people to revolt. It leads people to go--
甚至不要尝试做你那些愚蠢的抗议运动。所以某种程度上你是在杀死——如果你告诉人们一切都是阴谋，那不会引导人们反抗。它会引导人们去——
Give up.
放弃。
--well, then I might as well give up.
——好吧，那我最好放弃。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
But again, we might be overinterpreting here. But it's a book, so we're allowed to.
但再次，我们可能过度解读了。但这是一本书，所以我们被允许这样做。
Like I said before, Surkov is no longer the grand manager of propaganda in Russia. He was sidelined in 2011 after a dispute with Putin. But he stayed a personal advisor to the president, and he was also an organizer of Russia's takeover of the Crimean Peninsula in Ukraine in 2014. His involvement in that annexation got him sanctioned by the West, meaning he's not allowed to travel to the US or Europe anymore, and he can't have assets in the West either.
像我之前说的，苏尔科夫不再是俄罗斯宣传的大经理。他在2011年与普京发生纠纷后被搁置。但他仍然是总统的个人顾问，他也是2014年俄罗斯接管乌克兰克里米亚半岛的组织者之一。他参与那次吞并使他受到西方的制裁，这意味着他不再被允许前往美国或欧洲，而且他在西方也不能拥有资产。
Surkov was unfazed. "The only things that interest me in the US," he said, "are Tupac Shakur, Allen Ginsberg, and Jackson Pollock. I don't need a visa to access their work," which, you know, good comeback.
苏尔科夫毫不动摇。“我在美国唯一感兴趣的东西，”他说，“是图帕克·夏库尔、艾伦·金斯伯格和杰克逊·波洛克。我不需要签证来访问他们的作品，”这，你知道，很好的回击。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show. Surkov, by the way, seems to have been one of the people overseeing Russia's Ukraine policy until a few years ago. There's some hacked emails from his account in 2014 when pro-Moscow separatist groups in Ukraine had declared that two territories on the Russian border were no longer part of Ukraine.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人之一。顺便说一句，苏尔科夫似乎是直到几年前一直在监督俄罗斯乌克兰政策的人之一。有一些从他的账户中被黑的邮件，在2014年，当乌克兰的亲莫斯科分离主义组织宣布俄罗斯边境上的两个领土不再是乌克兰的一部分时。
In the email Surkov seems to be managing them. In one of the emails, Surkov received a list of potential leaders for these supposedly independent regions of Ukraine with asterisks by certain names as the best options. And he was asked in one email to edit a statement that allegedly came from Ukrainians living in the separatist-held territories. In 2020, Surkov was fired by Vladimir Putin without any public explanation. One headline about that read, "Putin fires his puppet master."
在邮件中苏尔科夫似乎在管理他们。在一封邮件中，苏尔科夫收到了一份潜在领导人名单，针对这些所谓的乌克兰独立地区，某些名字旁边有星号作为最佳选择。并且他被要求在一封邮件中编辑一份据说来自生活在分离主义控制地区的乌克兰人的声明。2020年，苏尔科夫被弗拉基米尔·普京解雇，没有任何公开解释。关于这一点的一条标题写着，“普京解雇了他的傀儡大师”。
Act Four, A Matter of Principle. Let's talk about the people in Russia who don't like Vladimir Putin. There have been protests against the invasion of Ukraine across Russia-- in Moscow, St. Petersburg, other cities. A group that monitors the protests, OVD Info, said that in just the first two days since the invasion over 1,800 protesters were arrested in 60 Russian cities.
第四幕，原则问题。让我们谈谈俄罗斯那些不喜欢弗拉基米尔·普京的人。整个俄罗斯——莫斯科、圣彼得堡和其他城市都爆发了反对入侵乌克兰的抗议活动。监控抗议的组织OVD Info表示，仅在入侵后的头两天，就有1800多名抗议者在60个俄罗斯城市被捕。
Back in 2017 when we first broadcast today's program, there were protests all over the country organized by Putin's most prominent critic, the charismatic opposition leader Alexei Navalny, about government corruption. In the years since 2017, Navalny was poisoned, fled to Berlin for treatment. German authorities said the nerve agent that poisoned him must have come from the Russian government. When he returned to Russia, he was arrested. He's in prison today.
回到2017年我们首次播出今天的节目时，全国各地都爆发了由普京最突出的批评者、富有魅力的反对派领袖阿列克谢·纳瓦尔尼组织的关于政府腐败的抗议活动。在2017年以后的几年里，纳瓦尔尼被毒害，逃往柏林接受治疗。德国当局表示，毒害他的神经毒剂一定来自俄罗斯政府。当他回到俄罗斯时，他被逮捕了。他今天还在监狱里。
But in 2017 he was turning out huge crowds of young people who showed up because of these great videos that he'd do online about the issues. After the protests teenagers started posting their own videos to the internet of their teachers lecturing them about the protests, telling them they were wrong about the issues, and the kids arguing back.
但在2017年，他吸引了大量年轻人，他们因为他在网上做的那些关于议题的精彩视频而出现。抗议后，青少年开始在互联网上发布他们自己的视频，视频中老师在向他们说教有关抗议的事情，告诉他们议题上错了，孩子们争辩回去。
You were called in for a lecture by your principal. You think the very idea of your principal lecturing you on the subject of protest is either unjust or absurd or funny or whatever. And so you film it and post it, just like, I think, a lot of 16, 17-year-olds might be tempted to do anywhere.
你被校长叫去听讲座。你认为校长向你讲授抗议这一主题的想法是不公正、荒谬还是有趣的，或者其他什么。所以你把它拍摄并发布，就像，我想，很多16、17岁的孩子在任何地方都可能想做的那样。
Joshua Yaffa is a correspondent for The New Yorker magazine in Moscow. And he wrote about one of these videos that was filmed in the provincial town of Bryansk, 200 miles from Moscow. Apparently there was a student there who tried to enlist other kids to go to the protests, which led to their principal and homeroom teacher to talk to them, which they filmed.
约书亚·雅法是《纽约客》杂志驻莫斯科的记者。他写了关于其中一个视频的内容，该视频是在离莫斯科200英里的布良斯克小镇拍摄的。显然有一个学生在那里试图招募其他孩子去参加抗议，导致他们的校长和班主任与他们谈话，他们录了下来。
It's obvious that it was filmed surreptitiously. You see a lot of the desk in front of you and kind of half cut-off shots of the school principal in front of a chalkboard.
很明显它是秘密拍摄的。你看到你面前有很多桌子，以及学校校长在黑板前相当切断的镜头。
OK, and I should say that most of it is just completely black. You see nothing, and you hear sound. And then occasionally the camera sort of bops up.
好吧，我应该说大部分完全是黑的。你什么也看不见，你只能听到声音。然后摄像机偶尔跳起来。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
She's essentially saying, with a tone in her voice that suggests you kind of naive, juvenile, somewhat immature in the ways of the world students are interested in this guy Navalny. What does he really stand for? What is he really offering or suggesting other than just getting rid of the country's leaders?
她本质上是在说，用一种暗示你这种天真、幼稚、在世界方式上有些不成熟的学生对这个叫纳瓦尔尼的人感兴趣的语调。他到底代表什么？除了摆脱国家领导人，他到底提供了什么或建议了什么？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
The principal says, guys, I can see that you're looking at this problem one-sidedly and that you lack range in your political view. You see Navalny, you watch his video, and boom, you believe it all.
校长说，伙计们，我可以看到你们片面地看待这个问题，你们的政治观点缺乏范围。你们看到纳瓦尔尼，你们看他的视频，砰，你们全信了。
When you wrote about this recording in The New Yorker, you described her tone as hectoring and frustrated.
当你在《纽约客》写到这段录音时，你形容她的语气是那种说教和挫败的。
I would say that that's really the most interesting or striking thing about the whole video to me, which is to me it sounds like Kira Petrovna, the principal, is experiencing something between confusion, exasperation, anger. I think she's really at a loss. She doesn't understand them, maybe, in the same way that-- I don't know-- five years ago, seven years ago, there was something more shared between her and her students.
我会说那是整个视频对我来说真正最有趣或最惊人的事情，对我来说听起来像是基拉·彼得罗夫娜，那个校长，正在经历某种困惑、愤怒之间的东西。我想她真的束手无策。她不理解他们，也许，以——我不知道——五年前，七年前，她和学生之间有更多共享的东西。
At one point she starts defending Vladimir Putin, saying, you can't blame him for the bad economy. That's because of the sanctions that the European Union and the United States imposed on Russia. And she says on the world stage and foreign policy he's doing a great job, which the students challenge.
在某一点上，她开始捍卫弗拉基米尔·普京，说，你们不能因为糟糕的经济怪他。那是欧洲联盟和美国对俄罗斯实施制裁的结果。她说在世界舞台和外交政策上他做得很好，学生们反驳了这一点。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
The student is asking the principal, OK, so what is our foreign policy? America is against us. Europe is against us. And the principal says, OK, well, why is that? What's the reason? And the student, without thinking, says, well, that's because of Crimea. We took it.
学生在问校长，好吧，那么我们的外交政策是什么？美国反对我们。欧洲反对我们。校长说，好吧，那为什么？原因是什么？那个学生，不假思索地说，好吧，那是因为克里米亚。我们拿走了它。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
And the principal, responding with some surprise or indignation, says, so was that bad?
校长，带着一些惊讶或愤慨回应说，那么那是坏事吗？
Because in most of Russia it's seen as like a patriotic thing to have taken Crimea.
因为在俄罗斯大部分地区，拿下克里米亚被视为一件爱国的事。
Yeah. The annexation of Crimea is incredibly popular. It's widely perceived to have been a good thing basically.
是的。克里米亚的吞并非常受欢迎。它被普遍视为一件基本上是好事的事。
And then the homeroom teacher jumps in and argues with the kids over Crimea.
然后班主任插话并与孩子们争论克里米亚。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
The teacher says, did we really take Crimea? Didn't they vote and choose to become part of Russia? The kids correctly point out, yes, Russia did take Crimea, and the sanctions were the result. Soon the conversation turns to the fighting in Eastern Ukraine. Russia officially denies that its soldiers are there, but all kinds of evidence has come out proving that this is untrue.
老师说，我们真的拿走了克里米亚吗？他们不是投票选择成为俄罗斯的一部分吗？孩子们正确地指出，是的，俄罗斯确实拿走了克里米亚，制裁是结果。不久对话转到东乌克兰的战斗。俄罗斯正式否认其士兵在那里，但各种证据已经证明这是不真实的。
And the principal is essentially trying to blame the crisis in Ukraine on America.
校长基本上试图把乌克兰的危机归咎于美国。
Let me read exactly what she says because it's so aggressive. She says, kid, you haven't read anything about this, and you don't know a thing.
让我读出她确切说的话，因为它太有侵略性了。她说，孩子，你还没读过任何关于这个的东西，你什么都不知道。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
You've got some very superficial knowledge here.
你在这里有一些非常肤浅的知识。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
What started this whole conflict? Maybe it was because America stuck its nose in. And then they start to argue.
是什么引发了整个冲突？也许是因为美国把鼻子伸进来了。然后他们开始争论。
Right. And the student asks somewhat mockingly of the principal, did you see American troops in Ukraine?
对。学生有些嘲弄地问校长，你在乌克兰看到美军了吗？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
And the principal says, did you see Russian troops in Ukraine? And this is this moment where the student reveals just this like basic, elementary, non-ideological factual knowledge, and the student just says, yes.
校长说，你在乌克兰看到俄军了吗？这就是那个学生揭示出这种基础、初级、非意识形态事实知识的时刻，那个学生只是说，是的。
Da.
是的。
There are videos going around. And then comes really maybe my favorite line-- you have no idea.
到处都有视频。然后来了我最喜欢的台词——你什么都不知道。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
And that to me gets to the key point of this whole dialogue, which is the kids just have access to this information and just a worldview that they've gotten on the internet themselves, information that's not on state TV. And that alone seems kind of somewhat destabilizing or uncomfortable for the principal.
这对我来说抓住了整个对话的关键点，也就是孩子们只是获得了这些信息，以及他们自己在互联网上获得的某种世界观，那些不在国家电视上的信息。仅此一点对于校长来说似乎某种程度上有点不稳定或不舒服。
The kids don't watch TV the way older Russians do. The principal tells them, OK, you don't remember how bad it was here before Putin. The country was in chaos. People had to carry guns and knives. And this is when I was in college.
孩子们不像老一辈俄罗斯人那样看电视。校长告诉他们，好吧，你们不记得普京之前这里有多糟糕了。国家处于混乱中。人们必须携带枪支和刀。那是我在大学时。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
When she says this and when she parrots talking points that you might hear on Russian state TV, she seems totally sincere. As an American watching this, it's one of the things that's actually most interesting about this video. You think that these government talking points on Crimea or Ukraine or whatever, you wonder if authorities are just mouthing these points and they don't actually believe them. When you hear the principal, she seems totally emotional when she runs through these talking points.
当她说这话，当她像鹦鹉一样重复你在俄罗斯国家电视台可能听到的谈话要点时，她看起来完全是真诚的。作为一个观看这段视频的美国人，这是视频中实际上最有趣的事情之一。你认为这些关于克里米亚或乌克兰或任何事情的政府谈话要点，你怀疑权威部门是否只是嘴上说说这些点，他们并不真正相信它们。当你听到校长时，她在讲述这些谈话要点时看起来完全是情绪化的。
But those talking points are, in a way, emotional, couched in the language of patriotism and appeal to history-- Russia as a great power, Russia as this besieged fortress surrounded by enemies who wish it harm. And the students just seem less receptive to those messages.
但这些谈话要点在某种程度上是情绪化的，包裹在爱国主义和呼吁历史的语言中——俄罗斯作为一个大国，俄罗斯作为被愿望不怀好意的敌人包围的被围困堡垒。而学生们似乎对这些信息不太接受。
At one point the kids openly laugh at the country's ruling political party, President Putin's party, United Russia.
在某一点上，孩子们公开嘲笑国家执政党，普京总统的党，统一俄罗斯。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
[SNICKERING]
[窃笑声]
We're against United Russia, the kid's saying. The student asked everybody to raise their hands who is against United Russia. And then you get the sense-- this part is dark in the video. You get the sense that lots of hands are going up.
我们反对统一俄罗斯，那个孩子说。那个学生让大家都举手，谁反对统一俄罗斯。然后你得到这种感觉——这一部分在视频里是黑暗的。你得到那种感觉，很多手都举起来了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语口述]
[CHATTERING]
[叽喳声]
This is one of the things that's interesting to me about this, because I feel like we read about how the Russian government sort of floods the zone in their own country with all kinds of misinformation and disinformation to make people feel that Putin is doing a great job. And here it seems like you have a bunch of kids who just seem utterly immune to it.
这是对此我感兴趣的事情之一，因为我觉得我们读到俄罗斯政府如何用各种错误信息和虚假信息淹没他们国家的区域，让人们觉得普京做得很好。而在这里看起来你有这一群似乎完全免疫的孩子。
Yeah. And that, I think, must freak out the political advisors and political technologists, as they're called here in Russia, in the Kremlin who just seem to have lost the country's youth. They just don't seem to be able to come up with the kind of messages and rhetoric that, for an older generation, worked so easily and naturally, and it flowed with so little resistance.
是的。而我认为，那一定吓坏了俄罗斯克里姆林宫里那些所谓的政治顾问和政治技术专家，他们似乎失去了国家的年轻人。他们似乎无法想出那种对于老一代人来说工作得如此容易和自然，而且流露如此少抵抗的言论和修辞。
Joshua Yaffa of The New Yorker magazine in Moscow.
《纽约客》杂志驻莫斯科的约书亚·雅法。
Well, the original version of today's program back in 2017 was produced by Jonathan Menjivar. Our update of the program today was produced by Chris Benderev and David Kestenbaum with help from Mike Comite, Katherine Rae Mondo, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney.
嗯，2017年今天的节目原始版本是由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作的。我们今天节目的更新是由克里斯·本德雷夫和大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆制作的，迈克·科米特、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼提供了帮助。
Special thanks today to Alisa Sopova, Oleg Krishtal, Dan Charles, Christopher Miller, Tanya Lokot, Mika Golubovsky, John Earle, Robin Hessman, Max Pozdorovkin, Matvey Kulakov, Andrew Wilson, Arkady Ostrovsky, Christopher Chivvis, Radio Free Europe Radio Liberty, John Dunlop, Yuri Felstinsky, Andrei Nekrasov, Anastacia Anishchenko, Ramzia Polizzi, Neli Esipova, Nikolai Zlobin, and Alexey Kovalev.
今天特别感谢阿里萨·索波娃、奥列格·克里什塔尔、丹·查尔斯、克里斯托弗·米勒、塔尼娅·洛科特、米卡·戈卢博夫斯基、约翰·厄尔、罗宾·赫斯曼、马克斯·波兹多罗夫金、马特维·库拉科夫、安德鲁·威尔逊、阿尔卡迪·奥斯特罗夫斯基、克里斯托弗·奇维斯、自由欧洲电台、自由电台、约翰·邓洛普、尤里·费尔什廷斯基、安德烈·涅克拉索夫、阿纳斯塔西亚·阿尼申科、拉姆齐亚·波利齐、内利·埃西波娃、尼古拉·兹洛宾和阿列克谢·科瓦廖夫。
Our translation of the Russian student video was done by the website Global Voices. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Obviously, like so many public figures, people ask him all the time, did he ever meet with Russian officials during the transition to Donald Trump's presidency?
我们对俄罗斯学生视频的翻译是由全球之声网站完成的。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。显然，像许多公众人物一样，人们总是问他，在唐纳德·特朗普总统过渡期间，他是否与俄罗斯官员见过面？
Nyet. Nyet. Nyet. Nyet. No!
不。不。不。不。不！
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。